Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Luca Ballistri
Buonasera a tutti.
Io sono qui per raccontarvi
un po' della mia vita,
perché da qualche anno a questa parte
trascorre scandita
da voli di aquile, falconi,
in dimostrazioni di volo,
nelle rievocazioni medievali
e nel bird control.
Quella della falconeria
è una strada in salita,
è una strada ricca di sacrifici
ma anche di soddisfazioni.
E di tante, tante lezioni da imparare.
La prima che ho appreso io
è che c'è una condizione senza la quale
nulla è possibile, con un rapace.
Ed è la sua fiducia nei miei confronti.
Se un falco non si fida di me,
non è assolutamente disposto
a collaborare con me.
E il primo rapace che ho addestrato
è un'aquila, un'aquila
delle steppe maschio,
si chiama Huracan.
Ed è arrivato proprio poco dopo
che io avevo cominciato
questo nuovo percorso di vita.
Io non ricordo la prima volta
che ho chiamato Huracan al pugno,
perché per tutto
il suo primo anno di vita
io l'ho tenuto sempre sul mio pugno.
Sono stata più con lui
che con qualunque altra persona.
Però non dimenticherò mai, mai nella vita
il primo giorno del suo volo libero.
Era un pulcino, si può dire:
aveva tre mesi, quattro mesi,
era pennato, pronto.
Ma ancora mi chiamava
come se fossi il suo genitore.
Pigolava ogni volta che mi vedeva.
Quando ho visto che era pronto,
che era in grado di spiccare il volo,
l'ho portato a volare su una collina.
Quel giorno c'era il vento forte,
che spettinava a me i capelli
e a lui le penne,
ed è partito dal mio pugno
e si è appoggiato a terra.
Ha scrutato per alcuni istanti
il paesaggio davanti a sé,
poi ha aperto le ali,
e in quel momento lì
il vento lo ha reclamato.
E lui era alto sopra la mia testa
che continuava a pigolare, a chiamarmi.
Sembrava che fosse quasi
in bilico nell'aria.
Poi io l'ho incitato da andare,
e lui ha preso a giocare con le correnti.
È stato un momento unico,
e davvero un'emozione grandissima.
Quando poi è stato il momento
di richiamarlo al pugno,
io ho visto questa sagoma
minuscola nel cielo
diventare sempre più grande,
sempre più grande e sempre più vicina.
E alla fine, con qualche colpo d'ala,
era di nuovo sul mio pugno.
Questa è stata un'emozione immensa,
ma solo una delle tante situazioni
che mi hanno fatto decidere
che la vita che voglio
è la vita del falconiere.
Anche andare a caccia all'estero,
e vedere aquile reali,
astori, gufi reali, falconi
al massimo delle loro capacità.
Vederli fare quello per cui
la natura li ha pensati, in realtà,
perché loro sono predatori.
Anche quello mi ha convinto.
Io non vi posso descrivere, a parole,
la bellezza, la forza
di una picchiata di un falco pellegrino
che rompe l'aria davanti a voi;
però vi posso dire che,
quando si assiste
a una situazione del genere,
davvero si ha quasi la voglia di urlare,
per la grandezza
di quello che si è visto.
L'addestramento di questi rapaci
si basa sui loro istinti,
fondamentalmente.
Io faccio, da terra,
quello che un genitore farebbe dal cielo.
I falconi, in particolare,
hanno sviluppato il volo
al punto da essere esso stesso
considerabile un'arma.
Per cui io, per insegnargli a volare,
per insegnargli a tirar fuori
tutte le sue capacità
di predatore, di volatore
devo simulare una situazione di caccia.
E per farlo utilizzo un logoro.
Un logoro non è altro che una corda
alla cui estremità è legata
una sagoma di cuoio
che riproduce un volatile,
oppure due semplici ali essiccate.
Io le faccio roteare in aria, e roteano,
e mentre roteano
il mio falco è libero in volo.
È libero e impara a volare,
impara le picchiate,
impara a fare le scivolate,
impara a fare le virate,
impara a prendere
le giuste correnti per alzarsi
e le giuste correnti
per prendere velocità.
È un po' una danza.
Dico danza perché bisogna prendere
il tempo, il tempo del falco.
Con tutta l'adrenalina che ne deriva,
perché credetemi che sono davvero
dei missili sfreccianti.
E l'adrenalina?
Anche quella mi ha legata a quest'arte.
Perché i rapaci non sono
animali da pet therapy.
Non sono affettuosi, non cercano
assolutamente di compiacerci,
non gli interessa il contatto fisico.
Lo permettono,
ma non è una cosa fondamentale
per instaurare un rapporto con loro.
Sono puro istinto,
anche dopo anni e anni
di nascita in allevamento.
E quindi un falconiere cosa fa?
Cosa faccio, io?
Io tendo non a domare,
non a inibire questo istinto selvatico;
vado a coltivarlo, vado a tirarlo fuori.
La soddisfazione più grande,
per un falconiere cacciatore,
è vedere che il suo falco
non tanto fa una cattura,
ma quanto che è competitivo
con un animale selvatico.
Vuol dire aver reso veramente onore
all'animale che si ha.
E nel volo libero, ovviamente,
dove non c'è una preda,
la soddisfazione più grande
è vedere la capacità in volo
della propria aquila, del proprio falcone,
e poi il ritorno al pugno.
Il ritorno al pugno è un momento magico,
perché non è scontato, assolutamente.
Perché nel momento in cui un falco,
o un'aquila, lasciano il pugno,
sono liberi.
E il loro ritorno dipende solo
da come noi ci siamo posti
nei loro confronti.
Bisogna lavorare sul rapporto prima.
E delle dimostrazioni di volo,
che io faccio per lavoro,
una cosa che amo proprio
mostrare alle persone
è non solo il rapporto che si instaura
tra falconiere e falco,
ma anche proprio cosa sono questi rapaci,
perché spesso e volentieri
non c'è una cultura
sul mondo naturale dei rapaci.
Le persone non sanno, spesso,
cos'è la differenza
tra una civetta e un gufo, ad esempio.
E c'è la possibilità di spiegarlo,
o di farlo vedere.
E io sono convinta
che il modo migliore per spiegare,
e per far apprezzare
e rispettare queste creature,
in natura anche,
sia proprio vederli in volo,
sia mostrar loro
cosa sono in grado di fare.
Vedere il mio falco
che sfreccia al logoro,
ignorando tutto quello che è intorno,
concentrato solo su di me,
è un'emozione per me grandissima,
ma che mi piace condividere con gli altri,
perché spesso succede che le persone, poi,
rimangono con il naso in su
a guardare nel cielo
e a domandarsi,
se vedono una sagoma passare,
che cosa fosse, cos'è.
Perché se qualcosa
lo si conosce, lo si capisce;
e se lo si capisce, lo si rispetta.
Io credo che rispettare questi animali
sia un po' come rispettare,
poi, anche la natura.
È per questo che amo molto il mio lavoro.
E anche se l'opinione pubblica
spesso è divisa,
nei confronti della falconeria,
io ci tengo a dire
che i rapaci che noi addestriamo
sono tutti d'allevamento.
Tutti.
E anzi, che spesso e volentieri
allevatori e falconieri
hanno collaborato con enti
per la reintroduzione in natura
di rapaci a rischio di estinzione.
Perché?
Perché la falconeria è una fonte infinita
di conoscenze su questi animali,
dato che è una tradizione antichissima.
Pensate - chiedo scusa.
Questo gesto, che io faccio,
appartiene ad una tradizione
che ha circa 6.000 anni.
6.000.
E nel 2016,
la falconeria italiana è stata proclamata
Patrimonio Immateriale dell'Umanità
dall'Unesco.
È stato un grande riconoscimento.
Io, da parte mia,
ho avuto la possibilità
anche di viaggiare, in questi anni.
Ho conosciuto falconieri
da tutto il mondo.
Sono stata in Spagna,
sono stata in Austria;
ho conosciuto falconieri kazaki,
è stata sempre un'esperienza
da cui ho imparato tantissimo,
viaggiare, confrontarmi con dei metodi,
con delle tecniche
di addestramento diverse,
fonti di tradizioni differenti,
sempre appartenenti, ovviamente,
al mondo della falconeria.
Alcune di queste persone,
che mi hanno spiegato i loro metodi,
hanno persino scritto dei libri:
io sarò sempre grata a queste persone,
a questi falconieri.
Ma non ho conosciuto solo falconieri;
io ho conosciuto anche
tantissime donne falconiere.
Tantissime, perché la falconeria,
a differenza di arti antiche
che spesso sono state precluse alle donne,
non è mai stata unicamente maschile.
È pieno di affreschi, arazzi,
rappresentazioni antiche, incisioni
di donne con il falco.
Donne, dame a cavallo con il falco.
E quindi, al giorno d'oggi,
c'è una forte presenza femminile
in questo mondo:
sono donne direttrici di centri rapaci,
allevatrici, bird controller, cacciatrici.
Siamo davvero in tutto il mondo.
Vai.
Adesso vi presento -
Vi presento Huracan.
Adesso ha il cappuccio,
vi spiego brevemente perché.
Questa non è una situazione
per lui consueta:
ci sono luci forti, ci sono telecamere,
c'è il tetto molto basso,
quindi è una situazione
in cui lui potrebbe stressarsi.
E il cappuccio è uno strumento
utilizzato in falconeria
molto comunemente,
ed è frutto di secoli e secoli
di studi proprio sui rapaci.
È fatto in modo che le cuciture
non creino nessun disturbo al falco:
non stringe rispetto
all'ampiezza del becco,
non va a toccare gli occhi.
È un semplice strumento
che gli impedisce di stressarsi.
Quindi è proprio per la sua salute.
Ebbene, con lui sul pugno io vi saluto.
E vi auguro di volare in alto
proprio come fanno le aquile,
anche controcorrente.
Perché un'aquila sa che,
che sia un vento forte
o che sia una brezza,
se vuole andare più in alto
deve andarci controcorrente.
E io vi auguro di seguire i vostri sogni,
anche di cambiare strada, se necessario,
lasciando tutto quello
che facevate prima.
Perché nella vita, certe volte,
fare un salto significa spiccare il volo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)